hi gq this is dicky your favorite
texture guru founder created author of
hair rules so many titles so little time
i'm here to take you through so-called
hard to manage textures wavy curly kinky
and show you how easy it can be
and there's a million and one textures
in between kinky curly and wavy of hair
types that are fine thin thick or coarse
there's a grading system that the
consumer or the community has picked up
and it's four three two one but they're
all textures the real value to the
grading system that it helps you to
accurately hone in on a regimen specific
to your hair texture so what we're gonna
do today and we found three great
textures and we're going to show you
step by step how to care for one in
terms of
hair care and styling all in one
leg has a very interesting texture it's
somewhere between a two and a three and
it's kind of a medium
fine-ish texture
that can be curly and what's great about
blake's texture is that depending upon
when and how you put your product on and
how wet the hair is you'll be able to
stretch out and get a more wavy appeal
to it
[Music]
with these textures what's so essential
is that you don't dry the hair out and
you're using a shampoo that is a cream
that allows you to start the detangling
process first while you're shampooing
which makes a lot more sense for
textures that have a lot of spring
tangles and coils and blake can go
between a low setting sulfate free
shampoo or a no such cleansing cream if
he chooses to shampoo every day we need
to clean blake's scalp and his hair and
detangle at the same time
and oftentimes guys who lead an active
lifestyle or it's warmer and warmer
climate like to shampoo their hair every
day so using a no such shampoo would be
really great for him so for blake
because his hair is longer um those long
that longer hair i call it elderly hair
it's been there forever so it's really
dry so if you're constantly shampooing
it with things that lather you're
constantly drying it out and creating
frizz so blake could use a no such
shampoo every single day without the
fear of his hair being dried out and
frizzy as you can see because it's
nonsensing
you're going to use it enough to cover
the hair so
you feel like something's actually
happening it's okay to use a wide tooth
comb
if you need to
so on blake's hair because blake has a
looser silkier wavier curlier texture
it's best to ring as much of the water
out before putting the conditioner part
on because it'll work more effectively
on his hair versus the other two tighter
kinkier textures which need
a lot more of the water in the hair to
move through the hair because it's
denser textures rinsing of shampoo is
the same thing it's like you're after
you've done your scrub detangle process
with shampooing um you essentially as
you're rinsing you're rinsing and
squeezing the water and product through
the hair as you're rinsing in a more
outwardly motion because remember
textures that have a lot of spring and
coils require a lot of lengthening in
order to get more definition and
elongation so as you're rinsing you're
not rinsing or doing this to the hair as
much as you are scrubbing cleaning
rinsing and detangling so everything is
in an outward downward motion the trick
with these textures right is that you
add as much conditioner as you have hair
on your head that's a big misconception
with kinky curly wavier textures they
have denser drier kinkier spongier
textures using a conditioner helps to
manipulate the hair texture and you
can't use a little bit of conditioner
and a lot of hair and expect anything to
happen so with your conditioner that's
when you comb your hair you don't comb
your hair when it's dry or when it
doesn't have conditioner and a
conditioner is there to serve one
purpose it's to help detangle soften and
help you to use a comb to get through
your hair without damaging your hair and
blake what he'll do is he'll use all of
his combing and manipulating his hair
while he has conditioner because he'll
do very little manipulating on wet hair
before he adds a styling product now
that we've rinsed and conditioned we
take a little bit of the water out of
blake's hair without disturbing his curl
pattern and squeezing the water out
and then we add a styling cream so
flake's going to use a kinky curling
cream like he normally would put his
products in his hair
styling happens almost instantaneously
after you've rinsed out your conditioner
and the key to really getting really
great definition
and elongation
and shine and luster without the frizz
when you use your styling products is to
apply them to sopping wet hair that's
the time when you've got your condition
your hair that helps to
prep your hair for your styling products
so you've got no frizz you've got the
perfect definition and you're adding
your styling product in the shower and
the key is to
not
towel dry or squeeze any water out until
after you have product in the hair
styling is a fixative and it helps to
fix the hair in the way that you prepped
it so now that blake has rinsed his hair
and prepped his hair for his styling
product and the key is to use a wide
tooth comb after he's applied it to his
wet hair it's a perfect ratio of water
and styling product and detangling and
styling and comb all happens while the
hair is super wet and again this is a
curl cream that will add some hold and
reinforce his waves and curls
without making it greasy or without
giving it a hard crunchy hold
so that it's a little softer more
natural
so now we're at that stage where
remember i told you that blate and his
hair texture could add on or cocktail
products we put the curling cream in
like combed it through and now we're
gonna add a water-based mousse to add a
little bit of hold and firmness to his
hair
so it's wavy mousse hero's wavy moves
pump about five pumps
and without disturbing his curl pattern
blade can kind of distribute it from the
roots to the ends because remember it's
a water-based mousse and it will
actually help speed up the drying time
so now we're moving on to styling or
drying right either air drying or using
a diffuser one of the benefits to using
a blow dryer with a diffuser is that the
diffuser doesn't throw the hair all over
the place last step is using a nice
cream as a polisher for groomed look the
great thing about
using some type of a cream or a balm or
polisher at the end is that it just
grooms the hair nicely and adds just
enough moisture without making the hair
look greasy and takes away any any frizz
and gets more luster and shine to the
hair
even though blake has long curly hair
his hair is groomed it's not frizzy it's
put together he could easily put on a
tux and go to an event and have his hair
be put together and rock long curly hair
[Music]
so silvio has a nice kind of they would
call his hair a 3c right a tight curly
texture
that has a lot of density and
what silvio needs really is elongation
and definition he has a lot of frizz
it's kind of a spongier texture that has
the ability to have a lot more
definition and curl pattern and
elongation so he needs a lot of moisture
[Music]
the unique difference between he and
blake is that he would be wetting his
hair more frequently because he has a
tighter drier spongier texture
so is no such shampoo would be his
primary shampoo that he used once a week
he would co-wash throughout the week if
he so needed to co-washing simply means
that you are rinsing your hair to clean
it like you do your body when you shower
and you recondition your hair most
important thing with the texture this
dense and thick and curly is water water
kind of breaks down the hair and softens
it up and reveals your natural texture
the biggest complaint i hear with
uh textures that are threes or fours is
that my hair is so thick it takes
forever for the water to go through it
that's generally from people who have
been told not to wet their hair every
day because it's really dry which makes
absolutely no sense because your hair
loves water and if you've got thick
curly coily kinky hair it should take a
minute and remember the most important
thing when you're shampooing is that the
no such shampoo cleansing cream will
allow him to detangling while he's
shampooing the no such shampoos or
co-washes so they call them
are really concentrated and once you add
water to them like i've done to
our cleansing cream they emulsify move
through the hair even better you know
it's often there's this misconception
that you need a lot of work with these
coily textures and i use conditioner as
a tool to help me to achieve definitions
if i've got a lot of conditioner in the
hair i'm able to work it through
and detangle and soak in the strands so
that my styling product my curl cream or
whip works more effectively your
conditioner reveals your natural texture
your styling product captures your
natural texture use as much conditioner
on your hair as you have hair on your
head if you want the definition
and elongation
to your hair and you've got thick kinky
coily coarse hair then conditioner just
helps to reveal your natural texture and
remember this happens really fast so
sylvia can put his head up slowly
and get his product
and a good trick to after you apply
product
to your wet hair sometimes you want to
re-wet it so it hangs even more
without rinsing it just re-wet it
so that's really it right so what you
see wet is how it will set and so we're
gonna go dry it now with the blow dryer
and the diffuser
now that silvio has dried his hair he
can put on another attachment on this
great dyson dryer and it's a condenser
and what it does is it helps to move the
curl around and release the curl pattern
the difference between silvio and blake
is that after silvio's hair dries he'll
stretch it out with his blow dryer or
his fingers for silvio's final step he
can take a hydrating finishing balm
which is a grooming cream for his hair
texture
and he can add a little bit throughout
the day
or after his hair is dry like it is now
just to add more luster and sheen to his
hair
and it also kind of softens it up and
he's able to get more movement out of it
[Music]
now we get to warner and he's got a type
4 kinky coily texture he's got really
thick hair it's really dense he's got a
lot of tight coils and so the objective
for him is to keep his coils and his
strands as elongated as possible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he has a tightly wound
zigzaggy
coily texture
which needs a lot of moisture and it
leaves a lot of conditioner and
rinse and repeat process so his shower
routine incorporates his hair every time
so we need to make sure that we get
enough cleansing cream no such shampoo
in the hair to help warner detangle and
elongate and scrub his scalp and keep
his strands tangle free so this is
usually the most disastrous part of
shampooing for
anybody who has a kinkier spongier type
4c texture is the shampooing traditional
shampoos are like putting gasoline or
alcohol on our hair right so it dries
out your naturally dry hair opposed to
you being able to use something that's
much more gentle innovative and
allowing you to detangle while you're
shampooing usually traditional shampoos
for these textures make it more
difficult to
detangle the hair using conditioner
after you've shampooed your hair with
something that strips it makes it just
feel not as crappy as it did when you
rinsed out the conditioner or the
shampoo so after we've gotten warner's
hair
cleaned 90 detangled
at his cleanse process now the
conditioner is going to work more
effectively
usually the conditioner just makes the
hair feel not as crappy as it did when
he rinsed out the regular shampoo that
dry out and tangle and mat up the hair
so at no point during his regimen has he
ever drying the hair out and this would
be warner's
once a week regiment of shampooing and
conditioning and so now that we've got
the conditioner and we've detangled worn
his hair
it's perfectly prepped for his styling
portion of his routine
and again all this happens almost
simultaneously in the shower
on sopping wet freshly conditioned
cleaned
coils
[Music]
and because 4c textures are the driest
within the texture spectrum
we add a little oil to seal in the
moisture we get really
literal when it comes to immediately
adding your styling product to
super wet conditioned hair with warner
because he has a four type texture and
remember the water and the conditioner
help to elongate and bring out his
natural texture so the slock method
liquid oil cream simply means wetting
oil
and locking in with your styling
products so it's really layering oil and
using oil more intentionally not as a
moisturizer okay so now we're just
reactivating the product remember i said
re-wet the hair if you like it's a great
tip to reactivate product so you get a
lot of definition and distribute your
product evenly through
your dense kinky hair
[Music]
so now that warner has dried his hair
he's going to switch out his diffuser
and add his condenser to the end of his
blow dryer like sylvia
another additional finishing product for
coily afro textures is that they can use
shine sprays which are great to add more
luster to your hair one of the favorite
tools of course among 4c textures is a
nice pick that helps to shape
and primp your coils and your froy hair
it's a great tool to kind of lift and
separate and it doesn't require you have
to pick your hair all the way through it
just kind of builds the shape in your
hair one of the misconceptions with
picks is that if you're picking out your
fro that's one thing but if you're
picking out your coils that you set it's
just about lifting at mid shaft or at
the root to lift and separate so your
coils have more pronunciation
[Music]
okay gq you've seen three different ways
to take care of three different hair
textures celebrating their unique
similarities and differences so may all
your good hair days outweigh all your
bad hair days
[Music]